pour les grecs demain c'est pâques la
plus grande fête de l'année la pâque
orthodoxe qui se célèbre avec un mois de
retard un peu plus d'un mois de retard
sur notre calendrier à nous et pour tous
ceux qui ne sont pas concernés ou ne se
sentent pas concernés par les événements
politiques qui viennent de se dérouler
dans le pays
la première préoccupation c'est d'aller
dans les petites boutiques spécialisées
acheter les guirlandes les oeufs
multicolores que l'on va offrir à la
famille à ses parents à ses amis aussi
d'aller brûler dans les églises dans les
petites chapelles que l'on voit un peu
partout les cierges et de préparer le
fils pascal qui aura lieu demain soir à
minuit à 7 fils pascal il y aura
d'ailleurs certainement beaucoup plus de
monde que d'habitude pour une simple
raison c'est que le nouveau gouvernement
le gouvernement militaire vient de
prendre un décret obligeant les enfants
des écoles a assisté à tous les offices
religieux nouveau gouvernement qui se
veut selon une tradition désormais bien
connu dur
épuré même moralisateur a aussi pris
d'autres décrets interdisant notamment
le port des cheveux longs et même celui
de la mini jupe
sauf pour les touristes bien entendu
d'ailleurs que l'on soit touriste aux
journalistes lorsqu'on est arrivé depuis
quelques jours à athènes ce qui frappe
c'est d'abord cette impression cette
impression d'une ville où il ne s'est
rien passé surtout pas un putsch
militaire il ya tout juste huit jours
les magasins sont ouverts
vous l'avez remarqué la circulation est
tout à fait normal c'est à dire toujours
aussi désordonnée échevelé ça vous le
voyez maintenant la foulée dans les rues
une foule d'ailleurs qui profite de ce
que depuis deux jours le couvre-feu a
été levé pour se promener très tard dans
la nuit et se mêler aux touristes
américains le long des pentes de
l'acropole ou dans le vieux quartier de
plaka athènes donc paraît tout à fait
normal à première vue tout à fait normal
à un détail près cependant c'est la
présence de ces chars de ces auto
mitrailleuses de ses mitrailleuses en
batterie qu'on est obligé de filmer un
peu en cachette car en principe toute
prise de vue est interdite en ce moment
à athènes
ces chars qui sont situées aux points
stratégiques de la ville devant le
parlement par exemple au pire est devant
le stade de olympique face à l'acropole
est aussi dans quelques terrains vagues
tout autour de la ville 150 chars en
prime athènes 150 chars maintenant il
n'en reste plus guère qu'une poignée une
poignée qui sont là comme une sorte de
symbole pour rappeler aux opposants
éventuel qu'ils n'ont plus pour le
moment qu'à se taire et à incliner la
tête ailleurs la vague d'arrestations
qui a eu lieu l'installation des
tribunaux d'exception la censure la
délation organisée par le gouvernement
ont suffi je crois à étouffer pour le
moment toute velléité de résistance
vous avez accepté de me parler mais
seulement dans l'ombre en cachant on
prend tellement de risques que cela
quand on veut parler librement ce moment
en grèce
ce qu'on est en train de faire est
passible lemay militaire on risque soit
la déportation sans jugement directement
sans que personne soit avisé c'est à
dire la disparition complète soit au
mieux la cour martiale
les tribunaux militaires les défendu de
divulguer des informations qui
pourraient nuire à la sécurité dit voilà
je crois qu'il est inutile de vous
demander ce que vous pensez du régime
qui viennent s'installer au pouvoir en
grèce il ne nous étions pas une pensée
mais tout de même ce régime il semble
avoir maintenant un semblant de légalité
puisque même le roi a accepté de
présider enfin de présider un conseil de
cabinet c'est bien notre année respar
disparaît réduc cette acceptation heroes
vous êtes monarchie non le superflic
non juste le républicain mais je viens
d'une famille qui était mon art schiste
pour des générations et je sais que les
monarchistes eux mêmes ont été déçus par
l'attitude du roi dont la fonction était
de protéger la constitution au risque
même de sa vie leroy n'existe pas en
tant que personne le rêve x existe en
tant que fonction il n'existe qu'en
fonction du serment qu'il a prêté de
défendre le peuple grec et la
constitution du peuple crack n'ai pas
l'impression que en approuvant coup
d'état il a en quelque sorte condamné
moins longue échéance la monarchie
l'onas certainement bien sûr à moins
qu'il y ait à moins qu'ils aient connu
t-il is set
ce fameux silence de quelques jours la
prétendue conversion qui est exercée pro
des fins de propagande ridicule mais qui
pourrait prendre le roi hérault c'est
que gouvernements en place dit qu'il a
eu l'approbation de toute la population
des élections étaient dans un mois et ce
n'est pas tendu mais on a l'impression
que même quand on se promène d'un tel
clavier normal on a eu l'impression si
honteuse apathie de la foule y si vous
voulez on n'a pas l'impression qui s'est
passé quelque chose ici quand fondra
patineurs qui tous les gens qui étaient
cavernes pouvoir à tête d'un groupe
structuré ce soit syndicaliste world a
déjà été déportés donc on se retrouve
des individus phase 1a les militaires
mais comment cela peut-il se terminer
avec le gouvernement en place dit qu il
n'est là qu'à titre transitoire pour
ramener l'ordre et qu'il laissera la
place ensuite aux institutions
parlementaires
normal il me semble que c'est un
leitmotiv de toute dictature
on peut pas savoir si ils vont continuer
en durcissant ou s'ils vont
monter un semblant de démocratie rien
endormir les gens de toute façon il n'ya
qu'une chose ça finira mari pour nous
penser que des petits noyaux de
résistance vont se former dans le pays
très certainement bien évidemment vivre
normalement comme dans n'importe quel
pays du monde libre c'est de la
résistance
l'iru penser ou parler c'est de la
résistance des gens ne croyez pas que
vous exagérez un petit peu les choses
non je ne crois pas dans le conte tant
qu'il y aura des lois nous défendent en
deux mais ils disent de divulguer des
informations qui pourraient nuire à la
sécurité du pays tant que n'importe quel
agent de police peut arrêter n'importe
quel homme sans aucune excuse dans la
rue fouillé une maison au lieu dit
maison sans mandat je ne crois pas que
les agir politiquement avant les
événements vous situiez comment vous
étiez à gauche bien sûr des boues
faisiez vous étiez communistes n'ont
aucun d'entre nous
[Musique]
moi personnellement je vais descendre
entre gauche molle gauche
vous auriez voté pour papandréou 28 mai
mme wynne pas pour l'homme mais pour les
[Musique]
enertrag et collèges de la ville natale
y en aurait le président est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que ce coup d'état
cette prise du pouvoir par les
militaires étaient inévitables la vie
politique malheureusement pour à des
patients d'un côté avec l'ambition
symbole de la famille papandréou qui
était devenu d'un dynasty le père au
fils voulait léguer un parti organisé
tout point de vue et c'est à dire la
démocratie le prêter les cercles de
démocratie le fils de plus la démocratie
l'autre côté le grand parti qui était
autrefois de caramany sur canal pourront
gaieté et à tout moment cherché à
prendre le pouvoir pour s'imposer à
votre parti il voulait à tout prix
monopoliser ou l'autre ou l'un ou
l'autre mon opposition de la vie
politique et la force du politique est
inévitable les militaires ont arbitré le
conflit entre les deux grands partis ont
pendant le pouvoir oui ils ont arbitré
où ils ont pu j'ai forcé ou son prix
l'occasion du conflit des conflits qui
serait jusqu'au bout d'un convenu entre
nos deux ans en partie et vous avez
l'impression que ce nouveau gouvernement
militaire de l impression qu il à
l'approbation du peuple
je ne peux pas l'aider pour le mange pas
des mecs vous voyez
ni le monde politique ne leur jette ne
réagissent pas nous avons tous la
confiance coupable mois ne preniez tous
il est démocratique le décret pense
fermement
il demande la qualité est aussi il est
attaché à sa liberté
mais comment alors un peuple qui est
attaché à sa liberté à la démocratie
peut-il accepter ce qui se passe en ce
sens je vous ai dit parce que tout le
monde nous d'abord revoilà avec nos
proclamation tout le monde nous disions
le lendemain ce sera les conflits dans
les rues le conflit sanglant le peuple
l'attendait snad attendait cela
lorsqu'il a vu quelqu'un qui est
intervenu comme l'armée alors il a dit
que c'était des moments pénibles mais
vous n'avez pas peur qu'une fois
l'humilité au pouvoir ils ne veulent
plus le redonner au peuple
je ne peux pas avoir je ne sais pas
son texte je ne peux pas ne pas répondre
pour eux ce que je sais c'est impossible
que ça dure longtemps
c'est à dire aller dernier en permanence
je peux pas l'accepter
monsieur le président caramanlis vous
avez gouverner la grèce pendant huit ans
de 1955 et 1963
quelle a été votre première réaction en
connaissant les nouvelles d'athènes
comme vrai démocrate je ne peux que
regretter profondément l'évolution
dramatique de la situation politique de
la grèce la crise actuelle vous at elle
surpris ce qui est arrivé je l'avais
prévu de toutes mes forces j'ai tenté de
sauver la démocratie en danger
j'ai essayé d'assouplir dans ce but les
habitudes politiques et de moderniser le
système de gouvernement
mes efforts sont restés inutile alors
j'ai pris la décision définitive de
m'éloigner de la politique qui
selon vous monsieur le président est
responsable de l'actuelle situation de
toutes parts les photos ont été
nombreuses le premier fautif c'est
papandréou de ses fautes découlent les
erreurs de la course
papandréou je vois cette année pas de la
faveur de la couronne et de la confiance
du peuple
s'il avait respecté la plus élémentaire
prudence le pays n'aurait jamais vécu
une aventure périlleuse d'aujourd'hui en
déclenchant la tempête des passions en
menaçant les institutions les
personnalités politiques la créer le
climat propice aux coups d'état
cependant tout ce qui se passe depuis
trois ans en grèce est tellement il est
logique que l'on peut reconnaître en
raison de confusions général des
circonstances atténuantes aux uns et aux
autres chercher des responsables
finiraient d'ailleurs par des
discussions byzantines et dangereux m'en
voyez vous l'avenir de l'avenir face aux
menaces intérieures et extérieures il
faut aujourd'hui éviter d'abord le pire
puis par des méthodes pratiques
retrouver une vie politique normale
[Musique]